(audience applauds)
It's time for Drew's News.
Hop on our back and we'll take you
for a good news piggyback ride.
And with me at the desk is my main newsman,
Rossy Ross Matthews.
(audience cheers)
That's right, everybody! Hi!
Hi, Drew!
Oh!
Hello, color!
I thought I had some of the brightest colors in the room
until I found out and saw you, ma'm,
with your hot pink vinyl trench coat.
I already saw her.
That looks beautiful.
I asked her if I could have the jacket.
Don't you find like, in the middle of winter,
it's best to wear bright colors.
It's just like, "Sorry, mother nature,
"but I'm a win today,"
and you are winning, Miss Barrymore, in that dress.
(audience cheers)
Hello.
Sorry, mother nature, I'm gonna win today.
I love that,
that's going to be my wardrobe North Star from now on.
(Ross laughs)
All right, first up in the headlines.
This one's fun.
Online dating is just never easy for anyone,
as you all well know.
I certainly know.
Apparently, it isn't for Zac Efron either.
Buzzfeed reports that Zac got on Tinder a few years back
and said he never even got a swipe right.
Well...
I know, I'm like, come on!
And it's not just him.
Shaq says that he struck out too.
You got a Zac and a Shaq and they both struck out.
And some celebs have had luck online though.
Simone Biles met her current boyfriend,
Jonathan Owens.
They're so cute.
On the dating app Raya.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, that's a big one.
I mean, I think, my only guess is that
what, people thought it wasn't really him?
Yeah, that's it.
I do buy that people didn't believe
it was really Zac Efron.
'Cause can you imagine not swiping right.
I mean, my finger would be bloody from like, swiping.
(audience laughs)
No, I mean I'm taken.
But before I was in a relationship,
before I was engaged,
I tried online dating once.
And this is a true story, I've never told you this before.
I was just gonna say, Ross, this is such fresh meat,
I can't take it.
What are you about to tell us?
So this is a true story.
I got on one of the apps,
I don't wanna say which one,
but I got on, and about four hours later,
I got a notification,
"We've removed you for impersonating a famous person."
(audience laughs)
And I actually wrote back to customer service,
I said, "Well, for starters, thank you.
(audience laughs)
"And number two, if I was going
"to impersonate a famous person,
"do you think I would choose Ross Matthews?
(audience laughs)
"No, I would choose Zac Efron, hello!"
(audience claps)
So I really think people just looked and thought,
"Yeah, right, you're catfishing me, buh bye."
First of all, I would pick you any day of the week.
Aww.
(audience cheers)
You are the best catch in the world.
I'd hook you, like nobody's business.
But you're right, if you were gonna fake it,
Zac Efron seems like a smart way to go.
Yeah, let me just say,
I've seen my abs
and I've seen Zac Efron's abs.
Yours are better.
(audience laughs)
Next up, a new study from the UK
looked at the TV watching habits of couples.
Do you guys watch TV with your partner,
if you're lucky to be with somebody?
(audience cheers)
It's like, one of my favorite times of the day.
Well, listen to this.
The Independent reports that at least a third of couples
spent a total, added all up,
of 43 days per year watching television.
I know that I spend at least 90 days a year
watching "90 Day Fiance," that is true.
(audience laughs)
Well, here's a sad stat, listen to this.
Only four percent of couples say they snuggle
while they watch TV.
Lame.
I mean, that's the whole point.
It's like, two people, one blanket.
You know what I'm saying?
Peas in a pod.
Exactly.
You must cuddle when you're watching TV.
And here's a bombshell.
58% of people say they watch stuff they hate
just because their partner loves it.
Ooh.
Yeah, I don't, I don't do that.
(audience laughs)
Okay.
This speaks to me.
Although it is not my love partner,
in a romantic sense.
I have two young girls.
And the amount of stuff I have had to sit through.
(audience laughs)
Oh, God! Kid stuff!
But when I wanna watch like, football or something,
Welly just watches something on like, his phone,
or Netflix on his laptop,
but we're still next to each other.
I don't like the like, "You go in that room,
"I'll be in this room" thing.
We can, hello!
I can do the separate rooms thing.
Oh, really?
Oh yeah, absolutely.
(upbeat music)